how are you doing today let's start out
with a massive thank you to folks who
commented and gave us corrections on our
last reveal trailer breakdown video
now it's time to see battlefield 2042 in
action which means swinging with the
grapple gun air dropping tanks getting
sucked in tornadoes specialist gadgets
we haven't seen yet and getting a feel
for what 128 players is actually like on
maps
here are all the things that you might
have missed in the gameplay trailer make
sure to like the channel and subscribe
so we can figure this all out together
let's get to it so the trailer starts
with a rapid fire tease of what we're
about to talk about in detail let's just
skip over this and go to the good stuff
we can now see the hourglass map in doha
cutter
it is actually a day map that gets dark
as the sandstorm progresses
players are coming from inside the
sunken stadium objective and there's
actually so much in the shot
new sector objectives can be clearly
seen which are a1 a2 and a3
you need to take those objectives to
hold a sector one of the many changes to
the new conquest mode this map has a lot
of air assets and tanks on it
some we can see here are a future
version of the osprey called the mv-38
condor it uses jet engines instead of
rotors
and this is the first time we've seen
one hovering there's also this russian
su-57 jet coming up fast from the enemy
team
a futuristic apache warchief the abrams
m1a3
and that really fast tracked vehicle
from the reveal maybe like a ripsaw
the perspective we're now in is the
specialist maria who's the medic she's
riding in the back of a night bird
chopper you can tell by her blue gloves
and stim pistol in the gadget slot which
we now know is the third slot in the
inventory keep an eye on that as the
trailer progresses
she's also rocking a dual side here
which is kind of rad as we get into air
combat the way the chopper's shifting
back and forth seems like classic
battlefield controls which will make
experienced pilots happy the great news
is for new players if you need to learn
to fly you can now go into full ai
matches
again what really stands out here are
just how many air assets are on this map
there's an su-57 a ka-52 alligator
an f-35 the apache warchief and a
slow-flying condor giving air-to-ground
support
[Applause]
[Music]
here we have the assault specialist
webster mckay their names will also come
up right here and you know it's a
specialist and not a username
because the usernames on the left side
are different he's rocking a scout
sniper rifle because guns aren't tied to
operators anymore
anybody can carry anything specialists
do have one
unique ability and one unique trait but
it is confirmed that they do
generally fall under the old umbrella of
classes
you can see the grapple gun ability here
third slot again webster fires his
grappling gun and it's surprising it
actually has physics and momentum like
the one from titanfall
2042 seems to be leaning heavily into
fun over realism this heavily armored
chap here is probably the delta
specialist who shows up a bunch in this
squad and whose gadget
is probably the thing at the end of the
trailer as webster lands he goes into a
slide we see this a couple times in the
trailer there's definitely like a
crouch slide just in time to see an
execution that's different from the one
in the reveal trailer
that might indicate their unlockable
executions in the battle pass or at
least
different ones per specialist man look
at how high we are there's so much
vertical space in this game it's really
awesome so now the sandstorm is coming
in part of this map's levolution that
functionally takes things from day to
night conditions
and we're seeing the condor with its
engines tilted forward going full speed
past the sandstorm
previously we only saw them hovering
we're in the third person which is
normal for the series
and these small rudder adjustments as it
flies are actually a really great detail
webster again running past a m1a5 tank
by the way all of you were amazing in
identifying this tank from the reveal
trailer as a future variant of an abrams
here's an airdrop something players can
do anywhere on the map with
a data pad that we don't actually see in
this trailer we also don't see a points
meter of any kind that might let you
build up to calling in these airdrops
not exactly sure how it's going to work
but there's got to be some limiting
factor or you'd just be able to spam
vehicles all the time in the last few
battlefield games the points only came
up on a radial menu for example when
you'd call in things like v1 rockets
interesting to note here is the tank
seems to have unlimited ammo it fires
six rounds but there's the infinite
symbol right here
so it doesn't seem like you're gonna
have to go back to places to reload
i'm not sure how i feel about that i
kind of like it when tanks have to go
off and re-arm and then come back to an
objective
this explosion here is too big to be a
vehicle and is probably some kind of
objective like an ammo depot
seems like there's gonna be great
moments around objectives here we see a
destroyed tank with its turret blown off
between this and the reveal trailer it
does look like there's going to be way
better animations for tank destruction
like turrets getting blown away in ammo
cook-offs jump to the very fast latv4
vehicle
you can clearly see there's a driver and
a gunner and two passengers
here we're in the gunner seat in the
developer presentation they said they're
trying to give abilities to
many of the seats in vehicles so
everyone has something fun to do rather
than just being along for the ride
as the chase ends note this is the new
unannounced specialist delta that we
talked about earlier i think this icon
is his handheld shield again you'll see
at the end of the trailer
a tank destroys someone's abandoned car
which is really rude definitely not
winning any hearts and minds here but
the detail here on the tank track is
kind of cool
and here are the jet wing tip vortices
that we saw on the reveal trailer
actually in the game should make it
easier for you to visually track where
jets are going
okay this is a bit of a surprise it
turns out that there's both a sandstorm
and a tornado on the same map so i guess
there can be levolution and extreme
weather events look at that lightning
detail we're also learning here how
players get warned about the extreme
weather events
if you notice here the heads up display
starts flickering as it gets closer and
closer
later you'll see players raise a hand
when they're close enough to get sucked
in
delta opts to avoid the tornado
altogether by ducking into a building
in this elevator we see the new plus
system where players can swap weapon
attachments on the fly
this vector is being configured for
close quarters with a red dot a
suppressor in a drum magazine
note there aren't any animations the gun
just transforms as you go
and it looks like delta's name is dozer
based on this armband and we're looking
through the eyes of another operator
sundance who seems to be associated with
the wingsuit and
these grenades i think are emp grenades
in a big brain move
dozer fires a rocket off at a scout
chopper forcing it down for a totally
not planned
jeep stuff moment and this is what the
real in-game version of the moment from
the cinematic reveal trailer looks like
you can definitely see it doesn't look
as good as the pre-rendered sequence and
you know don't have the benefit of slick
camera angles
to note again we are definitely high up
in this building which means more than
one map has huge vertical spaces and
that is so cool
here's an interesting detail the c4
seems to have a max range now so you
can't just set it on a capture point and
then clack it off halfway across the map
when another squad shows up and starts
capturing an objective
hopefully that's nine kilometers which i
think is bigger than the largest map in
this game
also here we seem to have some kind of a
long range sniper optic mount on a
revolver
okay zip lines here straight out of
battlefield hardline going from rooftop
to rooftop we're not sure yet if these
are in fixed locations or from a
specialist deploying them but the way
they're set on the ground here
does look like a specialist if i had to
guess a hind helicopter gunship shows up
and it is time to run as delta gets
taken out we have a first look here at
the downed icon the sundance specialist
jumps off a roof and pops their wingsuit
we don't see the gadget slot being used
here so unless it's some kind of passive
ability i would guess the wingsuits are
more common
maybe a piece of gear you have to take
with you because a lot of the other
players just pop parachutes
but full disclosure we've only seen this
swingsuit associated with this
specialist
i can't really make a call on this one
yet okay back to how players know
they're too close to a tornado there's a
hand raising animation here by maria the
medic in addition to the hud flicker
from earlier
that seems like your last warning before
you go airborne you can tell by the menu
here that we're looking through the eyes
of mckay now
being sucked in but he hasn't popped his
parachute yet so this is what it's like
being taken up into the tornado here we
now see that the parachute has steering
handles
but something this doesn't show is if
you'll finally be able to cut your
parachute in battlefield
when i went back to play earlier games i
totally forgot that you can't do this
like you can do in modern battle royale
games i'm nitpicking a bit here but the
helicopter flares and other projectiles
don't get sucked into the tornado which
would have been a cool detail
and a funny side note here if you look
really close you can see a soldier doing
barrel rolls with their parachute now
inside an mv38 condor that we just
barely got into
we can see its weapon slots and it has a
top gunner position which is interesting
because you couldn't get that on a
helicopter the condors seem like they're
going to be
very heavily armed troop transports
something we don't see anywhere around
here
is any kind of large-scale building
destruction buildings do not seem to
come down in this game
okay change a map this is the largest
one in the game called breakaway taking
place in antarctica we're back at the
outlook objective inspired by damivan
peak
that we saw in the reveal trailer this
now gives you an idea of how things look
versus when they're pre-rendered this is
back at the resource depot which is a
vehicle-focused area
and i know there are hovercraft here but
i was really hoping to see the penguins
from the reveal trailer
don't see any yet jump to discarded
taking place in india we're probably
fighting at the ship called the colossus
that contains a rogue nuclear sub this
tank is another abrams m1a5
more zip lines up here they seem to be
all over the place or they're being
deployed by a specialist
now we're inside the stadium most likely
back on hourglass in cutter you can see
here the a2 objective from the start of
the trailer
this seems like delta from earlier in
the trailer same armband and armor
has now opened a portable shield that
seems like that's his specialist ability
and he probably falls under
the support class umbrella off to the
left here there's also another operator
that seems to be deploying portable
cover
oh boy one thing to say here is the
brightness of friendly icons could be a
problem this is classic battlefield
where a friendly gets behind an enemy
soldier
and you think the enemy is friendly
because you see their icon this is
something that usually you can turn down
in the menu this gun also has a dual
sight so there seems to be a lot of
these in the game
to note here we're seeing white hit
markers i think there was a red one
earlier for vehicles
and i'm wondering if there's another one
for headshots that credit goes to
battlefield hardline if i remember right
for diversifying hit markers
and finally we get a look at maria's
surrett pistol in action she's the only
class that can revive from a distance
and brings players back to full health
jump back to orbital we see another
instance of a player calling in an
airdrop
here we see a column of vehicles with an
armored car and pickup trucks
so not everything will be futuristic
military and finally we end on delta
getting a close look at a rocket launch
something else funny i first thought
this guy was a giant mech soldier but if
you look closer he's just a player
riding up the side of the launch pad on
an atv
wow that was a lot i'm sure there's
stuff we didn't cover
missed or just ran out of time on you're
also amazing on our first video so
please hop in the comments i know i
skipped over guns altogether
e3 is in full swing make sure to head on
over to gamespot's youtube page where
we'll be covering your favorite games
through our play for all live streams
battlefield 2042 has several upcoming
alphas and betas with a final launch on
october 22nd
and i am excited thanks for watching
[Music]
you